joining me here from Sports Illustrated
back here on the Rich Eisen show is none
other in person here in Los Angeles
tonight's Heat Lakers game is the finale
it seems of the Dwyane Wade LeBron James
on the same court era Chris Mannix good
to see you sir
good to see rich I've always wondered
last time I was here are these chairs
like sheikah SH Li busted or just like
regular bus they're they need attending
to
yeah they need attending to I just think
though on television though it looks
like there she kishle bust okay
that's but since you are mentioning it
and I'm always honest with my viewers
and listeners I think it does need some
attending to yeah maybe would you like
it though I mean we can give it for your
closeout right I would say this no you
know would ticket is Paul papst like at
Paul paps and I are neighbors up in
Vermont I use his his house yeah he's
basically decorated by things that used
to be in the Dan Patrick studio it's odd
that Paul paps would be accused of
trying to use his Dan Patrick show
position to feather his own nest there
it's that is a shocker to me there are
some plush leather chairs in that that
Vermont man came from from like um from
the Dan Patrick show how do you stuff en
stuff I've sat in wow this feels this
feels familiar I get this what is that
is that a new fantasy team mate
I think that's a pretty good fantasy
name she kishle Bechet cuishle busted
pretty good I like it and that's the
avatar could be our chairs that have
been here since since day one okay where
do we start here from this weekend you
could start with let's start with the
Celtics making the Bulls the worst ever
on a single night that vase they lost by
56 points to Boston what does that tell
us about either team as it currently
stands right now I mean that was one of
those like the stat sheet just told like
50 different stories like Daniel theis
had like the fourth highest plus/minus
and NBA history was plus 50 something
I've never seen before person who not
adjust your sets in a game the Bulls
stink we we know that they had a nice
little win over Oklahoma City that gave
them a little bit of a bump but they're
a terrible team
I think it says more about the continued
advancement of Boston and gives us more
optimism that the Celtics are starting
to turn a corner I mean they were I
don't say prohibitive favorites but big
favorites to win the East coming into
this year they struggled with over these
last five or six games it feels like
they've discovered something and the
biggest thing I think they've discovered
is a lineup that works they started the
season rich with you know an offensive
point is starting lineup there five guys
Tatum brown Horford Irving and and
Gordon Hayward and that never really
worked there was no balance to that line
up they move Hayward to the bench Jalen
Brown is on the bench and now looks like
they have like two distinct units
they're starting to mesh together so if
the schedules been pretty lousy over the
last couple of weeks but I do think that
Boston is figuring some things out well
they're sitting there at 15 and 10 right
now with the Raptors having lost a
couple in a row you got the Bucks
sitting there as the two seed in the
East and if you think of 15 and 10 team
is figuring it out and making the
playoffs then you must definitely think
a 16 in 10 team in the West that you
said is not making the playoffs
nabis definitely going to make the
playoffs in the Los Angeles Lakers who
just beat down the Memphis Grizzlies on
the back end of a back-to-back to take a
half game lead over said team in the
Western Conference standings Chris
Mannix am i putting words in your mouth
I think so I think a few I am standing
by my prediction that the Lakers are not
gonna make the playoffs they're doing
things I didn't anticipate at the start
of the season you go back to like
Halloween Rich and you look at the
numbers then their defense I think was
27th in the NBA and you know you sort of
extrapolate that out and you say all
right well there's no way a team that
plays that bad a defense can be a
playoff team in a brutal conference as
we sit here talking right now they're a
top 10 defense now again the schedule
plays into it it's softened over the
last few weeks LeBron has been
superhuman but I looked at a team that
didn't have a lot of plus defenders and
I wondered how they would get to that
level they've gotten that level now now
the biggest question here yes is 10
LeBron keep this pace up he's playing
like 35 minutes a game once again rich
and
we all think LeBron is superhuman that
he's different that he's transcendent
but at some point this all has to catch
up to because it's not it's not 35 easy
minutes that he's playing right it's 35
lead the team in scoring rebounding
assists shoot you know 50 plus percent
from the floor he's got to do a lot of
things for this team to win games I
don't know they can continue doing that
over the course position well it's not
as if the cupboards bare and I guess
that is the conversation while we are
hearing the rumors that the Lakers are
in on Trevor Ariza right now on a three
team deal and whoever else they might be
able to bring in to improve the
situation that there are some young stud
like players on this team on this roster
that either have the ability to maybe be
and that's the phrase I've used here
before the analogy to Victor Oladipo
like to go from somebody who has
potential to boom superstar to be that
number 2 guy for LeBron or the sense
that that can't happen because LeBron is
doing too much where do you stand on
this chicken-egg subject I mean it's a
good way to put it more towards the
ladder I mean you mentioned Oladipo he
only became Victor Oladipo when he left
Oklahoma City and out of Russell
Westbrook shadow and became the man on
his own team is it possible down the
line that Brandon Ingram Kyle Kuzma
handful of other guys on that team
hearts has hearts been yeah he's coming
off the bench yeah I'm saying I mean he
can he just lit it up in Memphis he's
solid he said he made a lot of threes in
Memphis that's you know that's another
part of the Lakers that they need to do
to have success any given night but I
don't know I mean LeBron he's such a
high usage rate player that is it
possible for really anyone at this stage
to develop to the level that they could
develop to playing alongside LeBron
James now they can still be consistent
Hart is not an alpha Kyle Kuzma I'm not
sure really is an alpha these guys are
kind of built to play off of LeBron
James
but Ingram is the most interesting like
what would Ingram be yeah we saw what
Ingram could be last year you know 16 17
points per game on a bad team what would
Ingram develop into without LeBron James
there with LeBron there he's being asked
to play in the corner he's been asked to
cut do a lot of things to play
LeBron can he develop into that
number-two guy with him there that's
just a great unknown Chris Mannix here
in the Rich Eisen show and LeBron as we
all know from his Twitter feed slept for
11 straight hours from 8 o'clock to 7
o'clock slept through the Springhill
entertainment Christmas party that is
also happens called like Tuesday for you
that's right please tell me about I mean
I would love that
I'd love nothing more than have the
ability to do something like that it
also happened right in the period that
Ric Bucher is article had come out so
that was an interesting sort of dark
period I'm gonna flip this question for
you on its head a little bit Chris
Mannix next July the Lakers are in the
business of finding a Robin for LeBrons
Batman who are the other teams that will
be more attractive do you think based on
the sense that there are stars who don't
want to be that Robin what are the other
spots well I think I think the Clippers
have emerged as the most attractive
alternative they're doing what what they
said going into this year was that they
were going to rebuild and win at the
same time how many times we heard that
from from all sports this we're gonna
rebuild but we're not gonna tank it out
and that just never seems to to kind of
correlate the Clippers have done that up
until this point with good drafting
moves like getting montrezl harrell in
there they've done some smart things
with that team now not only do they have
the LA destination not only do they have
a elite level head coach in Doc Rivers
but they haven't they present an
opportunity for someone to step in there
as the Alpha B it Kawhi Leonard or Jimmy
Butler or somebody else you have a team
that's loaded with really good role
players that just needs a star that's
the exact opposite of the Lakers which
has the star but not the depth of role
players think the Clippers have okay
who isn't that interesting the Clippers
are sitting there at 16 and 9 right now
in the top of the and that's good for
fourth in the Western Conference the
Warriors have won three in a row
guess what they're now 18 and 9 atop the
West are we we chill on them now but we
cousins is getting ready to start it's
def coming back right
Steph back draymond is he back or coming
back or he's right there they're gonna
be fine
I mean he yeah
to to worry about the Warriors you have
to assume this anybody out there just to
boil it down beat them four out of seven
a full-strength Golden State Warriors
team how do you take four to seven games
against them the Rockets came close but
the Rockets blew up their roster this
past offseason with some of the the
ancillary moves that they made I don't
see a team out there Eastern Conference
play stirred conference that can do that
especially when you see what this team
can do when it's at or close to full
strength
okay couple more quick hitters for you
here Chris Maddox Luka Don check oh
right now it's just like this is a thing
yes it drives me it drives me bonkers
when NBA executives and I do this a lot
don't trust their eyes like nowadays a
lot of executives that they want to take
like the college freshmen or even
younger if you can get that if it goes
to that point a few years because they
want to take the potential they don't
look they look at a guy like Luke Adachi
who still has potential 19 years old
they look at a guy that Luka dodge ik
and they start to nitpick a little bit
they started to say look his athleticism
isn't at the highest of levels well who
cares when you're winning awards in the
Euroleague when you're playing for Real
Madrid since you're 16 years old
Luca Don judge and it's isn't an insult
to DeAndre eight and their Marvin bag
and their and those guys but Luca dodge
it should have been the number one pick
in the draft the Phoenix Suns should
have looked at him and said that guy is
a bona fide star based on the fact he
has already been a bona fide star in
Europe throughout his his teenage years
so I think the teams that passed on him
the two they're obviously Atlanta making
that deal and involving Trey young I
think they are gonna look back in the
years to come and say wow we really
missed on this guy well I think he's
already established in the league that
the most impressive thing about him I
think is that we're two weeks before
Christmas and the refs are already
allowing him that extra step has dropped
back drop in three-point of the hardened
move that they're allowing right now I
mean the number of times I've seen it it
blows me away every time I watch it I
have and I fully admit this slowed it
down on occasion there's a third step a
lot of the time the secret to that is as
players that have done that move or
players in other contexts players that
play overly physical if you do it enough
times the refs just say screw it he's
gonna keep doing it swimming too
let's undertake we can't we're not gonna
call it every single time so we're just
gonna keep keep doing it it's amazing
but he but like it's just amazing that
he's this I mean he is so fun to watch
like he has made the Dallas Mavericks
must-see TV it's amazing too that the
Mavericks are gonna go from 20-plus
years with Dirk Nowitzki to maybe
another 20 years with Luca Dodger two of
the already arguably the greatest
international player in NBA history to a
guy that has the potential to join that
list all right and where do things stand
with Trevor Ariza he's clearly in play
right now correct he is the guy that
right now every team wants I mean it's
it's it's borderline hilarious that
Phoenix signed him to a fifteen million
dollar per year contract and we're
talking in early December like how did
they get rid of him
Bob there-there were in 22 I guess why
bother signing him like I mean it just
right to maybe get an asset back in a
deal possibly but I'm not sure what
teams are at what the suns want right
now is either a young player being a
point guard or some other position and a
draft pick you're not gonna get that for
Trevor Ariza at this point there was
some talk in Philadelphia before the
marquel fold situation went a different
direction maybe you swapped marquel
Fultz for Trevor Ariza at this point the
bottom line with Ariza is that there are
a number of contenders that see him as
the guy that could help take them to
another level he isn't playing as well
this year as he did for the Rockets last
year but he's such a great glue guy he's
versatile he's a terrific locker room
guy they're gonna be a dozen teams
they're trying to get their hands on
Ariza either via trade or the hope that
they buy it the sun's buy him out before
the end of the season alright and I saw
he did get you know Jordan out of his
seat pumping his fist this weekend but
Kemba Walker is on a 13 and 13 team in
the East for the Hornets
is he in play too could he possibly be
coming out here to Los Angeles could
he'd be good on the move this year or is
he a next summer situation here's the
one question you have to answer if
you're the Charlotte Hornets
he's Kemba Walker approaching 30 years
old worth a five-year super max level
deal 220 230 million dollars this year
he's playing like it but a guy that this
has the size of Kemba Walker
often times if you look historically
they don't age all that well so at some
point with Kemba Walker you might be
paying a lot for past performance that's
the question if the Hornets say look you
know we're not gonna do that maybe you
can trade Kemba Walker and attach one of
their myriad crappy contracts that they
have on their roster to that like a Nick
Batum or somebody else if they do
believe in Kemba Walker they have all
the tools in the world to bring him back
heme boat
wants to be there he's basically mr.
Charlotte on the Mount Rushmore of
Charlotte Hornets if they're willing to
pay him
Kemba Walker is not going anywhere last
one for you here Carmelo what's the
school's take it out yeah he's on the I
think he's docked in the banana boat in
the marina ready for the call from the
Lakers LeBron is apparently reportedly
said he's not gonna say anything he
won't say I want him but if magic in
pálinka think that he could make a fit I
think he'd welcome it has LeBron ever
made an effort to play with Carmelo
Anthony hmm let me think about that one
for a second not really not really and
that's not to say he doesn't think that
they they could mix but he's never
looked at him as being the ideal
teammate for him right so that says
something Carmelo from what and I
haven't checked in in a few days or even
a week now but they're looking for a
team that wants him and the Rockets are
doing right by him keep him on the
roster I mean they could wave him at any
time
but they're looking around the league
for a team that wants the teams are in
stood in the past Miami not all that
interested right now Portland knowledge
too right now well I think they're
looking for in Carmela's camp are
waiting for is some kind of injury to a
team that has a player like him that he
could fit in but Carmelo Anthony and
I've kind of used this comparison before
he's an analogue player in a digital age
he can do one thing and he can't do it
as well as he used to be able to do it
so all his weaknesses become magnified
as a result good to have you here sir
thanks for joining Christmas out here
out here I mean we're just down the
street from the Lakers we're just down
the street from you know staples we're
out here just any time we'll see you
thanks for being here Chris Mannix is on
check them out on Sports Illustrated and
then locally in the Boston area as well
yes yes NBC Sports laws all right Chris
Mannix here on the rich eyes and show
the Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon
eastern on audience